[Music]
what would happen if the largest country
on earth decided it needs more territory
and power
well it might just go to war over it
what country could russia invade first
what would be the plan of attack
and what's the most dangerous weapon in
russia's possession
this is what if and here's what would
happen if russia started a war
russia already takes up one eighth of
all the inhabited land on the planet and
now it has its eyes on one of its
european neighbors
ukraine
historically ukraine and russia have
been in conflicts before
most recently russia annexed the
ukrainian peninsula crimea and then it
backed a separatist rebellion in eastern
ukraine
now
russia doesn't want ukraine cozying up
to nato
it wants nato out of eastern europe
period
and even though russia isn't a member of
nato to make decisions on such things
with one of the most powerful militaries
in the world
russia might feel like it can play by
its own rules
okay let's back up a little
first you might be wondering what nato
is
well nato is the north atlantic treaty
organization and right now it includes
30 members the united states canada
netherlands and the united kingdom are
among them
nato's goal is to keep the peace and
make sure no member of this alliance
gets invaded by an international
military force
you know like that time russia took
crimea from ukraine
now ukraine is not yet a member of nato
but it has shown interest in joining it
and that doesn't sit well with russian
president vladimir putin
putin is already a little freaked out
that nato is training ukrainian troops
and some members are supplying its army
with weapons
so he's decided to go about it with the
good old method of persuasion
he's threatening to start a war
now with a defense budget of 42 billion
dollars
russia puts a lot of love and money into
its military
russia's army counts 3.5 million
recruits
and it has tanks
13 000 of them
no other country in the world has this
many
russia also has 27 000 armored vehicles
and ranks first in the world with its
4465 artillery guns
and
then there's also russia's nukes to
worry about
all
6257 of them
these can be launched from aircraft subs
or missiles but if russia decided to
attack chances are it wouldn't start on
land
no the first strike would likely come
from the air
this could level electricity stations
and bridges
obliterate rail lines and crippled the
economy of any country attacked
in addition to this
russia's naval fleet is nearly
unmatchable
their nuclear-powered submarines alone
parked along a coastline could pose
enough of a threat to anyone thinking
about taking them on
depending who the targeted country is of
course
if russia attacked ukraine nato would
likely respond with heavy economic
sanctions
but russia has allies of its own
it's a member of the collective security
treaty organization or csto
this is a group of six former soviet
states in a nato-like alliance
it also has cuba in its corner
and if things should get really testy
cubo would be a key hub for russian
troops looking to do some damage on u.s
soil
it's pretty scary when 100 000 russian
troops are standing on your doorstep
but this likely wouldn't be a war to
wipe out the country chances are russia
has something to gain from it
it might be natural resources or
political leverage
whatever it is the plan wouldn't be to
obliterate every target in its way only
to do enough damage to make their point
in the case of ukraine it could shut
down the ukrainian economy
but they could do that with minimal
forces on the ground
war is also not fought the same way it
was even a decade ago
it can be much more covert
hack attack anyone
now if you worry about those russian
nukes well i might have an idea of how
to rid the world of them
how about nuking a volcano you know in
the name of science
go on see what happens
now
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]